apocalyptic battles alternate endings
and that time the Terminator killed
Santa Claus here's what you might not
know about Terminator 2 Judgment Day
warning this video contains Fast
Flashing images viewer discretion is
advised especially for those with
photosensitive epilepsy
looking back it's crazy to think that
anyone could have directed Terminator 2
other than James Cameron surely the same
guy who put together the original movie
would return to direct the sequel right
well for a while it was pretty much a
sure thing
I'll be back as early as 1985 rumors of
a sequel to The Terminator circulated
among various quorer and science fiction
magazines with Cameron telling Sena
fantastic that they had a story worked
out but not much else the following Year
Cameron directed aliens the Sigourney
weaver-led sequel to the original Ridley
Scott film upon the release of aliens in
1986 starlog magazine published an
interview with Cameron in which he
stated that while Terminator 2 was
probably coming he planned to let
someone else take the helm he reasoned
that at the time he had made more
sequels than original movies in his
career although Cameron apparently had
no interest in directing a Terminator
sequel he did confirm that he and
producer Gail Ann Hurd would still
oversee the project stating a few years
later that T2 was Gail's project as
you've probably guessed however Cameron
soon confirmed his own involvement on T2
he subsequently returned to both
co-write and direct the sequel
the Terminator features a few flashbacks
or Flash forwards that establish the
dark future from which Kyle Reese has
traveled these scenes depict the
horrific struggle between man and
machine one that results in countless
deaths and the near total Destruction of
Earth through all of it Kyle finds Solas
in a picture of a young Sarah Connor
studying it dutifully in preparation for
the events at the film these glimpses
into the future remain some of the best
scenes in The Terminator and something
fans at the time hope to see more of
going forward the way T2 begins it seems
like that's exactly what we're going to
get but this scene lasts for just a few
moments before the titles roll according
to James Cameron much more was supposed
to be shown including a full sequence in
which an older John Connor sets the
events of the first film into motion
from the future he turned it around he
brought us back from the break his name
is Connor
John Connor well we didn't end up seeing
John fight The Future war in T2 these
ideas would eventually be recycled in
the post-apocalyptic sequel Terminator
Salvation as well as the opening of
Terminator Genesis while it's a shame we
never got to see more of Cameron's
future War the mystery surrounding the
world of post-judgment day America helps
make T2 all the more exciting
it's hard to imagine anyone else playing
the role of Miles Dyson the brilliant
director of special projects at
cyberdyne systems portrayed to
perfection in T2 by Joe Morton before
Morton was locked into Judgment day
however director James Cameron
originally looked at Denzel Washington
for the Park Washington would later
comment about this to Premiere magazine
saying no offense to Jim Cameron but
when I read the script I thought all he
does is look scared and sweat I had to
pass while we'll never know what
Washington's version of Dyson might have
looked like we do know that it opened up
Washington's schedule to work with Spike
Lee on Malcolm X Washington has had an
incredible career and has even started
in his fair share of action movies
alongside his more dramatic roles though
it would have been awesome to see him in
Terminator 2. there's no doubt that
Washington made the right call opening
the door for Cameron to cast Joe Morton
as the self-sacrificing family man
Lance Henriksen has been around for a
long time possibly most beloved for his
role as former FBI profiler Frank Black
on the fox series Millennium and as the
Android Bishop in the alien franchise
Henriksen has played all kinds of roles
over the years having worked with James
Cameron on just about every one of his
early pictures Henriksen also appeared
in The Terminator as LAPD detective Hal
bukovic who tries to save Sarah Connor
from the Terminator although Arnold's
original T800 blasts his way through the
police station nearly killing Sarah and
Kyle Reese in the process detective
vukovic apparently manages to survive
the battle while promoting his reunion
with Cameron for aliens in 1986
Henriksen expressed his desire to return
in a Terminator sequel stating
you never see me die so I was telling
Jim Cameron that it could start in the
hospital with me covered with scars
saying look if this guy came once he's
gonna come again
given the track record between Henriksen
and Cameron it's easy to speculate as to
how T2 could have Incorporated a broken
detective vukovic into the narrative but
for some reason it simply never happened
filming a movie is often a stressful
Affair Anna can be even more stressful
on a picture as big as T2 but hey
there's always the holidays right
Christmas is a time when people can
relax enjoy being with their families
and ignore the tribulations of work for
at least a few days while many of the
cast and crew had the chance to attend a
T2 Christmas party in December 1990
however not everyone was so lucky during
that time James Cameron and his
post-production team were working hard
on the film's intense special effects
with Cameron himself editing his latest
Christmas Eve Cameron even convinced his
lead star to remain available for
emergency filming although Arnold
Schwarzenegger was initially unwilling
to submit to Cameron's demands he
eventually reconsidered and began
canceling his Christmas plans all right
but I need my foot massages my oatmeal
when Austrian Christmas music I need it
all this included an appearance at its
own Christmas party as well as when
thrown by his in-laws Schwarzenegger was
also planning on heading to Saudi Arabia
with then President George Bush to
encourage the troops overseas during the
holidays but was forced to cancel that
trip too in the early 90s it seems that
not even Santa Claus could escape the
wrath of The Terminator
of all the changes that Judgment Day
brought to the Terminator Universe
perhaps none have been more impactful
than the development of Sarah Connor
originally a scared young woman fighting
for her life T2 turns Sarah into a
badass Warrior who is hell-bent on
protecting her son and preventing the
apocalypse played by Linda Hamilton
Sarah's relentlessness proves time and
again to be one of her greatest
strengths and that includes the film's
final showdown when this happens get out
of the way John
time
to achieve this double Sarah effect
Linda Hamilton's twin sister Leslie
arrived on set with the pair appearing
together in a single shot this earned
Leslie a seat beside her sister at the
film's Hollywood Premiere not to mention
a spot in Terminator history
the first Terminator movie follows Kyle
Reese and Sarah Connor as they fight to
escape the hulking cyborg that has been
sent back in time to kill Sarah and
prevent the birth of her son Kyle
sacrifices himself in the final
confrontation and Sarah eventually
defeats the T800 by crushing it in a
hydraulic press in Terminator 2 Arnold
Schwarzenegger returns as a new
Terminator searching for John Connor
seemingly to kill him when Jon
encounters the T-1000 however the truth
is revealed Arnie is actually a hero who
has been sent back to protect the
Connors if you are one of the few to
experience Terminator 2 without this
twist being spoiled for you you were
truly blessed unfortunately for many the
trailers were no help in keeping this
one a secret and the big T2 twist was
spoiled in the marketing a mistake
repeated by many of its sequels some
markets were more Savvy though for
example the Japanese release of the
movie cut a number of trailers around
Sarah and John seemingly running from
Arnold's Terminator with very little
footage of Robert Patrick's character at
all
available on some home video releases
the so-called ultimate cut of T2
includes only a few extra moments but
it's especially notable for the
inclusion of the film's alternate ending
here we see an old Sarah watching over a
now adult John now a United States
Senator and his young daughter as they
play at a Washington DC playground while
the playground isn't especially
futuristic the buildings of 2029 are
revealing the DC has gone through quite
a change between the mid-1990s and the
movie's vision of the 2020s this
alternate ending feels pretty
unnecessary after Sarah's final Highway
monologue which allows for a little
ambiguity regarding the ending of the
theatrical cut the unknown future rolls
toward us I face it for the first time
with a sense of hope sequels such as
Terminator 3 rise of the Machines and
Terminator dark fate eventually proved
that Skynet wouldn't be so easily
defeated of course but T2 originally
ends with a sort of Schrodinger's cat
the future could be set or it might not
be thankfully the special edition and
Theatrical cuts of the film keep this
uncertainty intact and while it's cool
to see the alternate ending once it's
obvious why it was axed in the first
place
T2 3D battle across time was a
live-action theme park attraction at
Universal Studios one that cost 24
million dollars to make a mini sequel to
T2 in the form of a 3D movie within
theater effects battle across time is
the only film project to reunite the
movie's entire lead cast on the big
screen along with James Cameron behind
the camera this 3D experience saw John
and Sarah rescued from the T-1000 once
again by a brand new T800 before it
takes John to the Future to defeat
Skynet for good it's quite an explosive
experience and the filmmakers even
invented a few new Terminator models for
the production aside from a few
inconsistent plot holes the three weeks
of night shoots in the Arizona desert
really paid off not only does T2 3D look
great but it expertly combines film with
the stage like most James Cameron
Productions new 3D Technologies had to
be invented in order for battle across
time to become a reality while many fans
of the franchise wanted a third Cameron
directed Terminator feature set in the
future this is probably the closest
we're ever going to get if you're still
hoping to see it you'll have to travel
to Universal Studios Japan which is the
only theme park still playing the ride
today
[Music]